what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
spring water for another Sundance 2023
interview here's a movie I'm a big fan
of my animal
I'm so happy to talk to you about your
movie I'm a I'm a big midnight lineup
fan in general so my heart gets
especially full when I see a movie make
an impression like this one made on me
congratulations
I have a feeling you're being asked this
a lot I don't know who wants to do this
people out there don't know what my
animal is just yet who wants to give a
brief synopsis of the film
director
um I mean I think the way I like to
answer that is that it's a film for
Outsiders I mean it's a film about the
horror of the outsider
um and it's a film about it's also a
love story it's a story of Heather and
Johnny
um a hockey player and a figure skater
who meet and fall in love while coming
of age
um in the context of also a werewolf
film
this is a first feature for you and
that's that is a feat to pull that off
in and of itself what would you say is
the biggest misconception about what it
takes to get your first feature a green
light but then also what's a common
piece of advice you have heard that
actually did help you get my animal
through to fruition
I think the big thing is just like not
asking for permission I think it's just
about going out there and finding the
other people that want to make something
with you I think a lot of that is Cash
driven
um for me it's just like finding the
like perfect creative matches which I
felt like I really found with Bobby I
really found with a mandala and that was
the thing that set the project in motion
to really get made so that was like a
big I think that's a big part of it and
I think you just have to find the right
people for the role
um uh so I don't know I mean I just
think that sometimes you can get caught
into this feedback loop of trying to
find people like oh like will you make
this will you do this and I think you
just have to chart your own course and
like believe in the project or the
material and make it happen so I think
it's a really special thing when we find
the right collaborators that we want to
stick with in this industry so how did
you two find each other and then what
did you see in each other that signaled
to you like this this is a person that I
want to keep working with in this
business
okay well I'll I'll start just because
and then um continue on it I know it's
funny um so on my end it's really funny
because when I was at Sundance with a
short film a few years ago I met a
producer Todd Brown who's at XYZ films
and he's and now I'm rep there and he
knew about a project that I had and he
invited me to pitch that project in
Macau China um at a film festival there
so I pitched there and then I met my
producer Michael Solomon there who had
another interesting project
and so then he you know we kind of kept
in touch because he knew that I was
Canadian as well as American and French
and so he was like oh maybe we could
work on a project together and there was
one moment when he passed me he was like
oh I have a script I think you might be
interested and I was like okay like I'll
check it out and he didn't tell me who
had written it and then when I got it I
was like I saw Jay's name on it and I
was like that's so crazy because I was
in the music scene music videos things
like that in New York and I think there
was like a passing moment when Jay and I
maybe said hi in like a green room or
something like very briefly and so it
was really surreal to see that like Jay
was also working in film I just didn't
know that aspect of her and then I read
it and I just fell in love with the
world and the characters and then we met
up and decided to work together so
that's my side of it but Jay has a
totally different side too I mean
similar yeah yeah yeah so I am a
musician
um and I went through a very hard time a
couple years ago and I wrote a script
and I sent it to a very good friend of
mine alireza and I was like hey does
this suck and he sent it to Michael
Solomon because they worked together a
lot and I I didn't really know or I
didn't really understand kind of like
what that meant or like the consequences
of it but then Michael was like hey have
you ever considered optioning this I was
like what is that and then he's like I'm
gonna attach Jack to the option
so that's kind of Where it All Began we
then officially met at a bar in like New
York somewhere and just talked and tried
to figure out we had chemistry makes me
really happy that we're sitting in Park
City at Sun at Sundance and that kind of
connected the dots years ago it just
like goes to show what a special place
this is Bobby before we Loop you into
the conversation I want them to talk
about you a little bit what is something
that Bobby did in their interview in
their uh audition that made you say like
this is our Heather and and they're
bringing something to the role that
nobody else has and maybe something you
didn't even realize was in the role to
begin with actually
you know it's so funny because when I
sent this script over we didn't do an
audition I was just like Bobby Bobby's
it and I watched a lot of Bobby's movies
so like a lot of them all on a row I do
like lots of heavy research
um and I just like I it just felt right
to me it was in the middle of the
pandemic it was just like it was really
I think it was like May of 2020 it was
like everything felt really crazy and
weird and it's not like we were gonna be
able to meet up or anything even though
we were both in New York so it was just
like okay I'll send the script and see
what the response is and it was just
really immediate like like loving the
content and it just I don't know you
just you do a lot of work to try to find
the people that you think will be
attracted to the material as well you
know like I don't want to go out to an
actor who's just like oh I'll just take
anything you know you want to find those
special people that like actually
personally connect with the material as
well and it was really interesting too
because then I think there were other
elements of even before we approached
Bobby when we were working through some
of the screenplay there was like a
moment with like the shaved head scene
and that was almost kind of inspired by
I don't know if I ever told you that but
that was kind of inspired by you Bobby
because uh I had seen those pictures and
I was like okay this is like I don't
know so your story before you were even
involved got like into the DNA of the
script so I'm glad that you wanted to do
it yeah again yes
Bobby had you ever been in a situation
where you were just sent a script as an
offer did this Mark a first in that
respect um this wasn't the first but um
this was definitely one of the most
exciting experiences of that
um yeah I just immediately was like
completely in the world like you know I
don't know how fast I read that
script but I was like you know I got
through it and was just like
whoa you know I had gone through the
world and was just immediately fell in
love with the characters the world felt
so real and visceral and exciting and
you know I had there was like a little
bit of Social and cultural overlap with
with Jacqueline like just interesting
New York weirdo scene and I was a big
fan of boy harsher and I just was like
it was just a yes yes yes yes yes and I
was so excited
um yeah and then the first time we all
met up in person oh yeah
Upstate wolf sanctuary yeah
a crazy story behind too because so like
early on before we went out to you so
like I started getting really interested
in this Wolf Conservation Center and I
was like okay I'm gonna go visit it and
just like study wolves and stuff and you
can you can adopt wolves there it's just
symbolically like you donate money so
that they take care of their like food
and you know care and so on Jay's
birthday I was like I'm gonna adopt a
wolf under Jay's name and I did the
project for my animal and
um so I was like okay which wolf and
they have this whole like roster of
wolves and I picked uh Diane because
that's the goddess of the moon and the
goddess of wild animals and also I found
out later the goddess of like tomboys
and I was like that's super cool and so
I was like okay I'm gonna adopt this
wolf and so I adopt Diane and then uh we
go out to Bobby like I don't know nine
months later and I get this little
notification from the Wolf Center that's
like oh it's your you know you get
little updates or whatever and it's like
oh it's your Wolf's birthday and
um when I looked at it I realized in
that moment that the wolf that I had
adopted had the same exact birthday as
Bobby and I was like that's ridiculous
like how is that even possible and so it
felt really special so then we all met
up for the first time going to the Wolf
Conservation Center like in the middle
of covid we had to kind of like yeah
sneak yeah and like yeah private
appointment and then we all howled With
The Wolves together that was really a
moment yeah this all makes me so happy I
need I need that conservation
information too that's that's very much
right up my alley I love that stuff I
have so many follow-up questions um
Bobby I don't want to leave you yet a
two-parter about getting I like compound
questions the two-parter about getting
into Heather when you first started
looking into the role and preparing what
particular quality were you most excited
to bring to screen but then what is
something you discovered about the
character the more you got into it maybe
the more you shot of the film
um I mean there was so much in the
writing to work from which is just such
a gift because that's just not always
the case
um and also like in in conversation with
Jack and Jay like they both just had a
lot of cool exciting ideas and
um I did quite a bit of like physical
training for the role and was you know I
think my my personal prep was really
like about building Heather's inner
world and Heather's relationship to like
her body and like the experience of
having this like body that has this
capacity to like be scary and change
form and
um I actually thought a lot about you
know we were looking at women women
wrestlers women bodybuilders and um kind
of like the gender presentation of that
experience and we even
um I had a trainer who they had
suggested but was already someone I knew
from like performance art scene
um another redhead Butch cool person
whatever but
um yeah I was thinking a lot about um
like the psychology of dogs within kind
of like the wolf conversation and the
way in which training is so important
for like the mental health of dogs and
was thinking about that in terms of like
Heather's relationship to like you know
post the beginning of her realizing that
you know she's dealing with being a
werewolf
um you know when she's puberty
um working with like like intense
physical training to kind of like you
know control her body and like stay
connected to her body and have a
relationship with this really
complicated body that she's inhabiting
in like a town that you know she's not
totally accepted within so that's was
sort of like my early process and
um yeah just like approaching it from a
really somatic place
um I like put on 10 pounds of muscle
which I feel like no one noticed but I
did so that was cool
um I was like eating like five meals a
day at one point like I remember lifting
it was and then the movie got pushed
back a year
no um that's you know that's how it goes
but um the thing that was really
exciting to discover on set was learning
about Heather through her relationships
and you know it was such a gift that
like actually the the the order of
things we shot the first week we shot
all of the one-on-one scenes with the
mandala the Johnny character and that
was just such a nice Baseline to like
build this new part of Heather you know
this part of Heather that she's like
discovering about herself through the
movie
um and that you know like that was like
a kind of magic that could only happen
you know there and you know like on days
off me and Amanda would like you know
look at the script and talk about what
was coming next and you know we were all
just like really in it I have to
highlight Amanda here what is something
you appreciate about Amanda as a scene
partner that help bring something out of
your own character that you couldn't
have reached without her and maybe you
hope to experience with more Scene
Partners in the future
yeah I mean there were just so many
gifts about working with a mandala I
mean they're such a good friend and like
she's just such an incredible actor and
um
you know it was it's such a dream to
work with someone who you already have
you know trust and comfort with who you
respect who you know respects you uh
also shooting like queer intimate scenes
with someone who is also a queer person
and can like relate to those experiences
is makes it feel so safe
um but yeah I mean she's just a
really good actor so that helps you know
and and also just really generous you
know like we both would always like you
know
I don't know like little nerdy things
like staying for each other's coverage
even though like it you know there's not
an or anything that's really important
yeah like being like okay my turnaround
might be like a couple minutes less if I
don't if I don't leave but I'm like this
is an important scene and I want to like
be there for eye line like you know we
just did that for each other
the whole like we just kind of like held
each other through it in a real way that
I think you know was meaningful I'd
believe it I feel like you could feel
like the chemistry and the electricity
between the two of you leaping off the
screen and I feel like you can't achieve
that unless you put all that work in
behind the scenes as well back to the
werewolf thing I'm a big nerd for for
lore I love knowing every little detail
so I am curious have you two mapped out
how this curse works is it only
hereditary is it transmissible like what
does it do to the body how can one
control it if we if we experience more
of Heather's life beyond this story what
specifics can you maybe share
well I will say once you kind of give
your story to a director they are
allowed their own history but um
funny fact when I wrote it it was
actually a family of dogs
um and my understanding was it was like
an outsider family and it existed within
this unit only
um
because they carry the trauma with them
like that monster you know even any form
of transformation is like can be
horrific
um but then when we started meeting yeah
I think one of the first things Jack
said was like I really think it should
be wolves don't you think like that is
actually where that myth comes from
um but I Know Jack put in a lot of time
and math on like Moon cycles and that
becoming an actual part of the film
where in the original draft it was kind
of secondary
um because again they were dogs in the
beginning but
yeah yeah I mean I think I was just
attracted to
the wolf because of it being this very
feared creature this thing that is like
kind of shunned from society it's on the
outskirts there's a lot of interesting
mythology with it and I just was like I
don't know I really felt this movie felt
very much it was a night movie it takes
place at night we were doing night
shoots and I wanted to feel this sense
this heavy presence of like this like
this this moon was his own character
right and it's like it's completely uh
Lords over these characters you know and
if you were in that kind of situation
you would be super aware of that and I
just love playing with that and playing
with the the idea of the lighting for it
or how you would have that creep into a
scene or how it would just always be
present even if it wasn't like you know
really in your face so I don't know I
was just really I thought that was a lot
of really interesting parallels between
like the the wolf and like The Outsider
it just felt like hand in hand to me and
there was also something more dangerous
about it which I liked but I also like
what I really fell in love with with
Jay's script was that it was like subtle
and that it was it like you know when
you it was funny because Michael first
said it was a werewolf movie that's how
he pitched it to me and I was like I was
like I don't know like you know when he
first said it because I you know you
have this association with werewolf
movies being very like creature driven
and I wanted to do something that was
more like surreal in its approach and we
like actually shot with real wolves
that's why I went to go to like the WCC
and stuff because
um I just I thought that that was a lot
more interesting in a way to explore
that and like explore this surreal
connection of like is it happening is it
not is it just a metaphor for trauma is
it something beyond that you know and
like I thought there was something kind
of more interesting about that you know
way of exploring the werewolf like myth
without being too like aggressive about
it on the genre side so given how
successful you were with that for anyone
else out there who is making a werewolf
movie what would you say is one do and
maybe one don't I mean I guess it's
story specific depending on what kind of
character there are no rules I'm not
going to tell anybody how to make their
marriage that's the right answer I think
that they just need to go with what's
true to them and what they think is cool
like that's all you have to do just do
the thing you think is cool and that
will show through like that's what
matters I love that answer
um for all three of you now a little
cheesy but I feel like we don't tell
people in this industry good job nearly
enough so whether whether it's your
actors or someone who is behind the
scenes on this film can you each name a
time when someone just like absolutely
crushed their work and you want to say
good job to that person
I can start I mean obviously these two
Legends
um and I forget from Sister not curse on
this I feel like it's happened you're in
the clear okay
um but you know somebody's not at this
table right now Brian mccashin RDP was
someone who I really felt like his
dedication and love and his deep respect
for all of us you know on set and he
just he just rode so hard you know like
he just was in you know in the woods
with us in the snow like running through
the snow like he just was he really
brought a lot of
like dedication to the project in a way
that I want to like really shout out
definitely bran and I'll I'll do a
another example of somebody on the
ground in Timmins Ontario where we shot
um there is a guy there Brian Jones who
like I really have to shout out to
because he really made like everything
happen there he was a retired accountant
in his 60s and he got really into the
project he was doing location Scouts for
me like remotely with zoom and because
he it's a small town he did everybody's
taxes so he knew everybody in town and
so he was like oh do you need this type
of vintage car because I know this
person and I went to school with them
and their mom has this car and it was
like every step of the way he knew
everybody in town and we needed somebody
like that to be able to like really
secure like cool locations like you know
interesting extras like I mean he helped
with so much and he was also just like
you know we had like a covered shutdown
and he was like taking care of me he
like brought me food he brought me like
stuff from the store he like really
cared about this project in this way
that like was very touching to me
because I think I don't know like I I
live in New York and like you know
sometimes it's just kind of like yeah
whatever give me this money and you
don't necessarily get somebody on the
ground who really cares about the
project and this is somebody who really
like actually truly cared and I don't
know if we could have made the movie
there without him so I feel like that
needs to work on more projects He was
very yeah I mean he really had a good
sense of it like he he knew exactly what
I wanted with like location scouting the
photos that he got me were so helpful in
pre-production because it was
complicated with covid to be doing as
much on the ground as early as I would
want to do it so I had to really rely on
people like there to be able to share
all these like you know uh photos and
stuff because I think on a low budget
you really have to like have good
locations because you you know it's just
yeah anyways but Brian Jones I'm his
biggest fan he killed it it's incredible
and I would it's obvious but I would
have to say Jack
um like Bobby mentioned earlier there
was a period where the film was not
gonna happen you know and producers can
do their best but Jack literally was
fighting like I feel like you romance
Paramount like being like really far
away from the project but I remember I
was about to get on a flight and like go
on tour and Jack just called me and my
option was like a week away from being
up and Jack was like we're green lit
yeah it was pretty wild and you know one
thing I was gonna say about the first
question that was posed about like this
whole process was uh and meeting Jay and
stuff I didn't what I forgot to say uh
this was our first question was that I
was this huge fan of boy harsher so it
was like super cool when I got the
script because I was like oh man this is
crazy because before that like a year
previous to that I was working at a
different screenplay and I was like the
whole time I was listening to boy
harsher like the whole time and so it's
like it somehow manifested into my life
like I was like oh writing and listening
to boy harsher that's a writer from
boyar sure comes and like manifest into
my life so I I was like that was really
cool too like just it's like I don't
know it was like a media I was like of
course I want to work with Jay yeah
the project had to happen yeah there's
so many things that you guys have
described that just make me believe that
it was meant to be and all the hard work
that went into it really paid off
because this is something special and
it's so exciting to get to sit here and
tell people about a festival movie that
they're guaranteed to see in the near
future so congratulations on the movie
congratulations on being able to get it
out into the world which is a whole
nother achievement thank you for being
here thank you yeah to everybody out
there keep an eye out for my animal and
for more interviews from Sundance 2023